[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it seems to me that as a humanist
we have two options if you set aside the
idea that we are supernatural beings
handcrafted by god with eternal souls
one is to embrace naturalism to say well
okay if we're not supernatural we must
be just part of nature that is to say
where material objects essentially
including our material brains that are
wired into the material world
well i don't buy that because it
actually if you look at what's in front
of your nose it's clear that we're not
that kind of entity with something
rather different so my feeling is that
no we're not supernatural but clearly
we are extra natural we are at some kind
of distance from nature to say that
we're extra natural beings is really
uh to acknowledge something that is
blindingly obvious to everyone who isn't
necessarily
uh fanatically embracing materialism
feeling that's the only alternative to a
religious or supernatural view of the
world
so we're ex-natural in in the sense that
we can observe nature
we can describe it
we can even um form theories about it uh
we actually have the very concept of
nature and we're the only bit of nature
by the way that puts nature in inverted
commas we're only a bit of the universe
that embraces the universe and puts an
inverted comma so in that sense we are
outside of nature and the other thing is
we can genuinely act upon nature as if
from the outside what evidence is this
well
i offer you the anthropocene as the most
spectacular evidence of our individual
and collective agency we have
transformed nature so much so the
anthropocene is regarded as the present
phase of the universe
so that's for starters that's the broad
brush picture of ourselves as both
observers of the world and from a
standpoint of observation able to
manipulate it in directions that we have
at least in part chosen
[Music]
i think we'll step back a bit because i
know what's implicit in that case
statement the notion that we are somehow
superior to everything else in nature
and that this arrogance will end in
tears hubris leads to nemesis and so on
and so forth actually my position isn't
that i believe that yes we're not part
of nature but i don't think we're sort
of superior to it
for example i don't think we're superior
the chimps i think we are just
incommensurable with chimps with trees
with ants and so on and so forth we have
something uh quite different and yes
there is the worry that
it all seems to be ending in tears that
our collective and shared agency
is leading to uh consequences that all
of us are increasingly aware of
climate change etc etc
but the very fact that we're aware of it
means that we are at least able to take
steps to head it off whether we do or
don't is a matter of political
commitment and all those other things
but i don't know any other species
that's destroyed its own habitat
and then set about repairing it or
better still anticipated the destruction
of its own habitat and set about
preempting that
so
yes there are dangers in our collective
agency our collective power but again
our awareness of those dangers is a
measure of our uniqueness again i'm not
saying our uniqueness makes us superior
i think we're just incommensurate uh
with other things
and it's probably worth exploring a
little bit more of how did we get to be
so different
to be honest i have
published a trilogy on precisely that uh
10 or 15 years ago
which looked at how it how we got to be
so different
because i'm
a darwinian i'm not a creationist
and so if one's going to produce an
explanation of how we escaped biology to
the extent that we do
now we don't exclude it completely of
course as a medic i'll be the last
person to believe that
but how did we get ourselves so distant
from biology and for that we must have
some kind of biological explanation and
there's all sorts of just so stories
that you can write as i say i published
a three volume just so story and that
that gives um priority to the hand uh to
the upright position
the predomination of visual predominance
of vision
and ultimately to language but language
is a par venue it's a recent
arrival perhaps who knows forty thousand
hundred thousand three hundred thousand
years ago but actually uh we were
already very different probably a
million or more years ago
and i've talked a lot about early tools
and axes and pebble choppers and so on
the means by which it came to be so
different was a bit of biological luck
and we built on that
but that process of our becoming
different has accelerated enormously
um
in the last well
100 thousand or three hundred thousand
years and particularly in the last
thousand years and particularly in the
last 100 years especially the last you
know 10 or 20 years
and one of the keys to our um
as it were becoming more and more
distant from nature
more able to manipulate it
is
our ability for us to share our
consciousness in an explicit way
human consciousness is woven out of
joined
intentionality and you can see that
present very early on in the lives of
human beings
i don't know whether you've got ever had
you had any babies yet but those those
of us who've had babies know that long
before language at least a month or two
before language emerges the child is
communicating by means of pointing it's
sharing its experiences
pointing is a human universal
and it's unique to humans at least
so-called declarative pointing is and
that ability to share our experiences to
acknowledge a common or shared world
to create a public sphere is central to
the process by which we gradually become
more and more distant from nature
[Music]
logos is an interesting term it's a very
loaded one it sort of first came into
human discourse as far as i'm aware of
in the pre-socratic philosophers people
like um hickory heraclitus
but it was embraced by christianity
through the mediation of philo eggs alex
fallow of alexander extraordinary writer
who brought together the hebraic and the
greek traditions
but logos is um i use it
in my book of that title
as our capacity to make sense of the
world as a world as a whole instead of
making sense a bit of this and a bit of
that
you know like for example a dog sniffing
out some a source of ascent or whatever
we try and make sense of a world as a
whole
and the journey um that leads to world
pictures from sensory experience
is an extraordinary journey it involves
universals it involves um
exploratory techniques in the search of
principles it involves looking for laws
that go beyond merely patterns
and so on and so forth so logos in a
sense is us it's our sense
of the
intelligibility coherence
of the world
that things that are superficially
different
perhaps dance to a single tune
[Music]
well i have actually published a book on
parmenides whom i admire enormously
and in the sense he format of the disc
on which all subsequent philosophers
have written their files
so you got that right and you may be
familiar with
parmenides but some of the listeners may
not be he was the person who said
basically that the universe
is a single unchanging homogeneous
entity
you think well that's rubbish i mean
aristotle himself said it was madness
um and
parmenide's argument was essentially
that
being is
but that which is not cannot be
so clearly that which is
cannot come out of that which is not
so there can be no as it were emerging
nor indeed can there be any exit into
something which is not
being is end of story so there's no not
being so there's no space in his
argument for change nor is there any
space for the distance between beings
there's no space if you like for
emptiness
and that's the reason why he felt uh
that the um
universe was a single homogeneous
unchanging blob
now that's wrong but like all great
philosophy it's interestingly wrong and
it's profoundly wrong and it's the
profundity that one's willing to take on
board even if it leads to
what aristotle called lunacy or didn't
call it madness
and it seems to me what um
parmenides brought to the party was to
say look two things i'm going to argue
for my position
it's not revelation from heaven it's not
what the gods have told me or the
authorities i'm going to argue for my
position and basically i'm going to
follow the argument wherever it takes
takes me and if it takes me to a place
of matters well well good it may well be
the case that normal common sense
understanding is wrong now it was wrong
it was interesting wrong but actually
it's something that has proved
it if he likes inspired the collection
in quite a collective inquiry ever since
and although empiricids would scorn at
what um
parmenides said if you look at say the
general theory of relativity the notion
of the spatial temporal continuum
ultimately there is centrally no change
in the spatio temple commit continuum
except that which is imported into it by
observers
and that's roughly what palmetto is
saying he was saying it's uh the
illusion that comes from observation
that makes us think there are changes
but he says ignore your senses look to
the truth
so in many ways parmenides anticipated
the general theory of relativity
um so there's
something to be said for parmenides the
greatest of the um pre-socratic
philosophers
whitehead very famously said we can look
upon the history of western philosophy
as footnotes to plato
actually we can look at plato as a
footnote to power amenities and i've
stolen that idea from elizabeth anscombe
but essentially i think we're all of us
as it were either
responding to or disagreeing with
um parliament is and that's
he is the man basically who collectively
transformed
uh intellectual consciousness his
extraordinary
thoughts were an amazing self-encounter
of humanity
[Music]
[Music]
gosh thank you for asking that question
uh the present book i'm writing its
final chapter is called the battle of
the genre
and it just seems to me that
from poetry we can get certain things
the ability as it were
to pick something out
and to
look at it
and and through this this individual
thing try and reach something deeper
there's a famous
dialogue of goethe when someone says to
him why do you write occasional poetry
he says no great poetry
is occasional poetry
if i write about a blackbird singing
i've cut to the heart of creation
but the truth is that poetry is still
fastened inevitably to particulars
what does philosophy being philosophy
brings clearly very general inquiry but
the trouble is they sang
exsanguinated when you're talking about
being and knowing
and so on you've lost all the wonderful
variety of things
the drunken variousness of things as uh
louis mcneese would say
so great
fantastic scope philosophy thank you but
you've exsanguinated everything as a
result of trying to see everything at
once so then this fiction
and of course what fiction brings to the
party
is the story of stories
of individual human beings
possibly as examples of the human
condition
so there is a narrative direction in in
um
in fiction
but wouldn't it be wonderful to write
something that brought together what
poetry does
what fiction does and what philosophy
does
and the answer is nobody's done it
people have tried um hybrid
um
genre with varying degrees of success or
strictly varying degrees of failure and
if you think about philosophical novels
like the unbearable likeness of being
it's quite light on philosophy quite
good on uh fiction um but on the whole
you would think well philosophy 101 is
okay to import in fiction
we could do with a little bit more
profound philosophy so i don't think
anybody's cracked that as a result of
which instead of doing something that
brings these things together
you do things that actually
express them or
exemplify them in in succession so the
two books i'm writing the moment well
the one i've just finished is coming out
on free will is straight philosophy
the one i'm right at the moment called
prague 22
a um book of tenuous connections is a
series of essays with poetic asides
it's got a bit of philosophy because the
underlying theme is um
that when you visit a city which is
the city of the title you are an
embodied subject who's removing your
body around the streets and so on and so
forth but i've got a feeling that the uh
philosophy doesn't dissolve successfully
uh into the narrative
i mean i've written up in the loft where
they're turning to peter and many
manuscripts of books
that tried to combine philosophy and
fiction in particular
but it's a bit like trying to get the
lumps to dissolve in the custard they
still remain
absolutely um
basically uh separate
news subscribe today to the institute of
art and ideas at iai tv
you